well in case you hadn't noticed I took a
big chunk out of my face what happened
wait are you serious did you have you
noticed it yeah no shaving I never do
that anymore I thought the dermatologist
no no but it's it's funny because here's
the thing I did this two days ago and
you know that I'm just shaving
um but are you just shaving or are you
like yeah
Sona tell them this is honest this is
true I think because because you've
witnessed what you do is just very like
I just want to get this over with right
like so I feel like you're just like
angrily that's what I shout as I'm
making love I just wanna get this over
with
that's hot it's been 40 seconds
this is intolerable